>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
WE NOW RESUME OUR EXCLUSIVE
INTERVIEW WITH FORMER
>> Shannon: CAMPAIGN
-- CARTER, WHEN I SAW THAT THEY
STARTED TO LISTEN INTO YOUR
PHONE CALLS IN OCTOBER, THAT WAS
AFTER THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN PUT A
TERMINATION ON THE RELATIONSHIP
WITH YOU.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, WHO WANTS
TO WORK IN ANY CAMPAIGN?
IT'S AN INDIVIDUAL, AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, CAN BE SURVEILLED
BY THE USE OF A DOSSIER THAT WAS
FUNDED BY THE OPPONENTS, THE
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
THEY ARE ALL WORRIED ABOUT
RUSSIA AND THEIR TACTICS?
I MEAN, RUSSIA DOES STUFF LIKE
THAT, FRANKLY, TO THEIR
POLITICAL OPPONENTS.
YOUR REACTION WHEN YOU FOUND OUT
THAT YOU ARE CALLED AT THAT
POINT WHERE SURVEILLED?
>> THE FUNNY THING ABOUT IT
LITERALLY ONE WEEK LETTER WHEN
THEY WERE HACKING ME AND WHY
YOU'RE TAPPING ME, ONE OF THE
EMAILS I SENT OUT FIRING A
COUNTRIES IS A PART OF, THEY HAD
AN ELECTION MONITORING SYSTEM
GOING ON IN THE UNITED STATES,
MONITORING LEGAL INFLUENCE AND,
YOU KNOW, ELECTION RIGGING.
I LODGED A COMPLAINT THERE.
I THINK ONE OF THE FIRST THINGS
THEY WERE PICKING UP ON WAS MY
LOAN COMPLAINT THAT I SENT TO
VIETNAM AND THE OSCE
WHAT THE REACTION WAS TO THAT AT
THE AND MAKE.
>> Laura: ONE DID YOU LEARN,
CARTER, THAT YOU WERE OF
INTEREST TO THE FBI?
IT PREDATED THAT, ACCORDING TO
THE FBI
DID THEY EVER CALL YOU OUT OR
TRY TO TALK TO YOU.
SAYING, WHAT WERE YOU DOING OVER
THERE IN RUSSIA?
YOU ARE EVER DELL MAY VERY WELL
CONNECTED.
DID YOU EVER APPROACH THEM?
>> I MENTION THIS, I SENT A
LETTER TO DIRECTOR COMEY ON
SUNDAY, SEPTEMBER 25TH, 2016, 2
DAY AFTER THE DEFAMATORY
ARTICLES CAME OUT AGAINST ME.
AS I MENTIONED THERE, I
BASICALLY TOLD HIM EVERYTHING IS
THIS WITCH HUNT, WHICH IS WHAT I
CALLED IT, PLEASE DON'T HESITATE
TO CONTACT ME.
I WOULD LOVE TO SET THE RECORD
STRAIGHT AND TALK TO YOUR
AGENTS.
IN THAT MEMO TO MR. COMEY, I
SAID, WELL, I'VE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH MEMBERS OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY BEFORE, MANY, MANY
YEARS, I WOULD BE HAPPY TO HELP
OUT, AGAIN, IN TERMS OF
PROVIDING YOU SOME ACCURATE
INTEL ITSELF.
>> Laura: WHAT YOU ARE
PORTRAYED.
AND PEOPLE WHO DON'T KNOW YOU, I
GUESS PEOPLE READING QUICKLY
THEY HAD LIKE, OH, CARTER PAGE
IS A SPY FOR RUSSIA.
I THINK THAT'S WHAT REGULAR
THEY BELIEVE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY THINK.
>> I MEAN, I WAS A WITNESS.
THERE WAS A DIPLOMAT HERE IN
NEW YORK WHO I HAPPENED TO MEET
AT A CONFERENCE.
AND WE STRUCK UP A CONVERSATION.
I MET HIM ONE TIME AFTER THAT.
I ACTUALLY WAS TEACHING A COURSE
AT NEW YORK UNIVERSITY.
I TOLD THEM A COUPLE OF THINGS I
WAS TELLING MY STUDENTS ABOUT.
HE WASN'T REALLY INTERESTED.
I SENT HIM A COUPLE OF COARSE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU.
SOME THINGS DON'T REALLY MAKE
SENSE TO ME.
TO THE ACADEMIC PRESS?
WERE THEY QUOTE YOU AS SAYING
OVER THE PAST HALF YEAR, I HAVE
THE KREMLIN DURING THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE G20 SUMMIT
NEXT MONTH OR ENERGY ISSUES ARE
POINT ON THE -- DID YOU WRITE
THAT?
>> IS TOTALLY TAKEN OUT OF
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE AS A
FORMER ADVISOR TO THE STAFF OF
THE KREMLIN.
>> THE G20, PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
AROUND THE WORLD --
THE ONE WE ALL KNOW THAT.
WHY WOULD YOU WRITE THAT?
>> I WAS OFFERING -- I WAS
INVITED TO PROVIDE SOME -- THEY
PUT TOGETHER A ROUNDTABLE OF
ENERGY EXPERTS.
LITERALLY PEOPLE FROM AROUND THE
WORLD, TOP COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
>> Laura: IT SOUNDS LIKE, TO
ME, YOU ARE REALLY...
YOU WERE REALLY CLOSE TO THE
STAFF OF THE KREMLIN THERE.
THE WAY IT'S WORDED.
I MEAN, I WOULDN'T HAVE WORDED
IT THAT WAY.
WHAT HAPPENS IS PEOPLE SEE THAT
AND THEY SAY, WELL, HE WENT TO
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT WHEN YOU
WERE WITH THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN?
WHO SIGNED OFF ON IT?
WAS IT REALLY A COVER FOR A
MEETING WITH GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS?
I KNOW THAT'S WHAT PEOPLE THINK.
>> THIS IS WHERE CONTEXT IS
IMPORTANT.
BASICALLY IT WAS SOME IGNORANT
ACADEMIC WHO SUBMITTED -- IT WAS
A COPY OF MY THESIS.
THEY WERE CONSIDERING IT AT A
ACADEMIC PUBLICATION.
THEY WERE COMING AFTER ME WITH
ALL THESE FALSE CONCEPTS ABOUT
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING ON IN
RUSSIA.
ACROSS EURASIA AND THE
MIDDLE EAST, ASIA, EUROPE.
ESSENTIALLY HAVING SERVED, BEING
PART OF THAT INFORMAL GROUP, WE
HAD A COUPLE OF MEETINGS.
BIG DEAL.
>> Laura: I GOT IT.
I THINK GOING TO MOSCOW IN
JULY 2016, YOU ARE JUST SETTING
YOURSELF UP FOR SCRUTINY.
I MEAN, DID SOMEONE IN THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, DID THEY OKAY YOU
GOING LIKE MIKE DID YOU ASK
THEM?
I'VE SEEN VARYING ACCOUNTS OF
THAT FROM YOU.
DID SOMEONE SAY "GO FOR IT" --
>> THERE WAS NO "GO FOR IT."
BUT WHEN DID YOU TELL ANYBODY
FROM THE TRIM CAMPAIGN THAT YOU
WERE GOING?
>> I'VE BEEN GRILLED MANY HOURS
IN BOTH CHAMBERS OF CONGRESS.
MANY TIMES.
I GAVE THEM A HEADS UP AND THEY
SAID, YOU KNOW, IT'S FINE TO GO,
BUT YOU HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> Laura: YOU ARE ACTUALLY
SUING -- ARE YOU SUING THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
I THINK I SAW IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" TONIGHT,
PUSHING A RELEASE FOR ALL THE
UNDERLYING DOCUMENTS IN YOUR
CASE.
AND ONE OF THE ARTICLES THAT'S
MENTIONED IN THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE MEMO FROM FRIDAY,
IT REFERENCES ONE ARTICLE.
ACTUALLY, THAT WAS REBROADCAST
BY STATE PROPAGANDA AGENCY IN
WASHINGTON.
BROADCASTING BOARD OF GOVERNORS,
FUNDS RADIO FOR EUROPE.
FOR THE LAST 70 YEARS, MOST OF
ITS HISTORY, IT WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE USED FOR, YOU KNOW, OFFERING
IDEAS TO COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
THEY CHANGED THE LAW IN 2013.
AND NOW THEY CAN PUSH GOVERNMENT
PROPAGANDA IN THE U.S.
THIS WAS THE FIRST SELECTION
WHERE THAT EVER HAPPENED.
WHEN SEAN ON HIS SHOW WAS
REFERENCING A LIST OF QUESTIONS
THAT'S RUN BY STATE DEPARTMENTS.
>> Laura: THE BROADCASTING
BOARD OF GOVERNORS.
THE YAHOO! NEWS STORY OUT.
BUT YOU ARE ASSUMING THE BIKE
HAS BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND WHO
ELSE, VERY QUICKLY?
>> THE PARENT COMPANY FOR YAHOO
AND "HUFFINGTON POST" WHICH HAS
A TON OF ARTICLES.
>> Laura: CARTER, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU SPENDING SOME
TIME WITH US TONIGHT.
EVERYONE'S OUT FOR AN INTERVIEW
FOR YOU.
I JUST THINK, AND THEN IT'S AN
AMERICAN -- I MEAN, FROM MY